Jésus-Christ, c'est Jason Bourne à chaque
aéroport dans lequel je me trouve ou à chaque fois que je
marche dans une rue et que quelqu'un m'arrête,
c'est la première question, est-ce que tu vas
faire un autre de ces films de Bourne que
j'aime faire ces films,
ça ne me dérange pas d'être  suivi par
Jason Bourne J'aime Jason Bourne, cela a
été un rôle déterminant dans ma vie, donc
je veux dire que j'ai toujours été incroyablement
reconnaissant de m'avoir donné le rôle que vous savez
il y a seize ans, c'est bon de
voir ma planche, je suis ravi d'être  travailler à
nouveau sur un déménagement de Paul Greengrass,
c'est une personne formidable pour qui je travaille
juste pour eux complètement, vous savez, c'est comme
une famille, n'est-ce pas ou ne bouge pas, c'est un peu
comme un groupe de rock qui revient pour faire une
bonne vieille tournée que ce film trouve  lui dans un
endroit vraiment sombre et il enfonce essentiellement d'
autres êtres humains dans l'
oubli juste pour essayer de faire face au
renard dans sa tête
le monde change et bouge très
rapidement le monde est en guerre nous avons besoin de l'
arme parfaite pour revenir maintenant il y a
une raison  pour le C  IA vouloir
le ramener
il a froid l'oncle l'
arme à un million de dollars je sais qui je suis un monde déchu pour
commettre des opérations pour compromettre les
gens vont mourir tu dois arrêter ça
car tu es Jason Bourne cette fois
pour toi tu as toutes les réponses  à
cette question d'identité originale, donc c'est
vraiment très excitant Je me souviens de
tout,
me souvenir de tout ne signifie pas que vous
savez tout ce qui est une grande poursuite dans le
film Bourne plus grand que je n'ai jamais
eu